My name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's only
Spider-Man and things are going great sorry
There's an elite crew with all the best spider-people in it, Peter!
you have a baby I knew I was gonna
regret making her that web shooter
don't tell Mom what do you want you
I'm robbing you because I'm a bad guy
You can never be part of this
don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
199999 this is Doctor Strange sounds like
he maybe shouldn't practice medicine reason
that I do any of this in the first
place I will always be here for you
getting pretty good at being a parent did you
bring our baby to another fight no no no and
then they go and grow up he's a good kid
I just don't want to lose him stop him now
you gotta let him spread his wings man
Gwen! I'm here to help. Miles, you're not supposed to be here.
Who's that?
Hey, who's the new guy? He Pav. I'm sorry. Who are you? I'm glad you asked new guy! I'm not a new guy.
My name is Pavitr Prabhakar. I live in the best possible Spider-Man city Mumbattan.
this is where the traffic is this is also
where the traffic is the traffic here too
I think Spider-Man is so easy I wake up
skip the workout because I'm naturally
buff and I don't want to get too big you
know quite a few bad guys quick break for
a cup of try with my my auntie I love chai
tea what did you just say Chai Tea
Chai means tea bro. You're saying Tea Tea.
would I ask you for a coffee coffee
with room for cream cream no no miles
there's chapters that are part
of every Spider story every time
you have a choice but been saving one
person and saving an entire world every world
no no you can't run forever kids I'm
just as much as Spider-Man as any of you
miles come on this tension is so palpable
how can you guys even concentrate all
you had to do was listen everyone keeps
telling me how my story is supposed to go
All stations stop what you're
doing and stop Spider-Man
Miles, Miles Morales. He's entering sector 4
do I uh have web on my face, what's the deal?
Could this day get any weirder
I guess it can
And then I looked at my uncle
Uh, lemme guess. He Died.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my new Spider-Man across the spider-verse
trailer obviously a bunch of cool live-action
Venom crossover footage in there so I'll explain
what's going on with that because it supports
some of my theories about how they're bringing
these spider-verse characters into the live-action
Universe in preparation for Secret Wars a lot of
that's also preparing them for what's happening in
the next spider-verse movie which they're calling
Spider-Man beyond the spiderverse and I think
part of the play on those words means Beyond
animation like into live action so it has begun
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's a whole
bunch of stuff coming up of course I'll do more
videos for the movie as it gets ready to come
out too there's so many really cool really huge
literally and metaphorically things happening
during all this new footage so I'll just start
with the biggest stuff first obviously the
live-action Venom stuff what it looks like
is happening is they're confirming in this scene
that the spot's ability allows them to portal to
other universes and he's going to a bunch of
these different universes encountering these
other versions of Spider-Man and in one instance
he goes to the Venom Universe where all these
and movies take place like we're getting ready for
Venom 3 to start filming I just did a whole bunch
of videos about that so I'll link them Below in
the description But the spot goes to Mrs Chen's
Bodega and steal some gum and if you zoom in hands
on the gum it says Venom mint so they're actually
creating merch based on Venom that Mrs Chen is
selling maybe she has something to do with this
too because it's a bit of a play on the idea
that even in Miles Morales Ultimate Spider-Man
universe he's been Spider-Man long enough that
they've actually started to create merch based
on him like the little kid at that funny scene
where he says that he doesn't want to wear the
mask of Miles Morales and Spider-Man anymore
because he botches the save against the spot
here when they're fighting amidst the bubbles I
don't think I want this costume anymore I don't
know how much more Venom or other live-action
characters we're gonna see in this I think
initially we just assumed that there will
be some live-action version of Tom Holland
MCU Spider-Man crossing over like Toby Maguire
Andrew Garfield because there have been other
Easter eggs with those characters in previous
trailers don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and the Little Nerd back on Earth 1999-99
range sounds like sounds like practice medicine
did it work look they have all the scenes of
them making fun of doctor strange and the nerd
from Earth 19999 which is a play on Tom Holland's
MCU Spider-Man in the events of Spider-Man no way
home Tom Holland even said that they tried to have
a cameo with him in the first Spider-Man into the
spider-verse movie but at the time they needed
him he was busy working on Avengers Infinity
War Avengers end game as well as Spider-Man far
from home so there was just way too much stuff in
his schedule the next time we'll see Spider-Man
we'll be in Spider-Man 4 which isn't coming out
till 2025 so there's plenty of room for him to
have Cameo scenes what I think though is that we
won't see the spider-verse characters themselves
the live-action versions until Spider-Man beyond
the spider-verse they'll just be teasers and
crossovers with live action elements like the
Venom stuff happening in this movie so they're
sort of easing you into live action combined
with animation crossing over which they kind of
did during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
when he and America Chavez traveled through
the Animated Universe so even on the MCU side
of things they've been preparing people like oh
yeah animation and live action in the same movie
if the characters from The Animated Universe
or universes travel to a live-action Universe
they would also become live-action versions
of themselves even recently Haley Steinfeld
was asked about this too because she plays Spider
Gwen in the ideas that spider-gwen will eventually
come into live action heading into Secret Wars
but she also plays Kate Bishop in the Hawkeye
series live-action MCU she'll be in Avengers 5
King Dynasty and some version of Secret Wars 2.
what's gonna happen if those characters meet on
screen it's a little stupid I've thought about it
um who do I think actually wins wow you know
so it seems as much as I thought about it I
don't know that I have the answer I think they're
both highly highly capable uh and and skilled the
way she answers the question you could tell that
she's thought about it but she doesn't know for
sure whether or not they might actually do it so
she's trying to waffle and not answer the question
like oh okay that's a really good question like oh
you clearly have thought about this but the funny
thing about that is that because Kang Dynasty and
Secret Wars are still so far still a couple years
away they don't tell the actors about that kind
of plot like if spider Gwen were actually going
to meet a version of Kate Bishop they wouldn't
tell her years ahead of time she probably wouldn't
even find out until she saw it in the movie
theater but I think at the end of Spider-Man
across the spider-verse we'll get a teaser for
Spider-Man beyond the spider verse and that's the
movie like by the end of that movie you'll see
the live-action versions of these spider-verse
characters one of the other biggest new scenes
too is when he's fighting the rest of the spider
Army they're calling the spider society when he's
running from the rest of the spider Society here
hiding on this Spider-Man's back this version is
called Max Bourne who's from a distant future that
was part of an organization called the time
Spinners another Spider-Man joke protecting
the timeline like a version of the TVA from the
Loki series but a bunch of versions of Spider-Man
a lot of you theorizing that because Secret Wars
is going to be an amalgam of a bunch of different
versions of Secret Wars like the 80s version in
the more modern version what they might wind up
doing is when they bring these spider-verse
characters into live action is instead of the
thoracor they might actually substitute the spider
Society in live action so you just get many many
many versions of Spider-Man in secret Wars that
would actually be pretty cool and even though
there are billions of versions of Spider-Man in
this I've already talked about spider cat he's
one of the Miles Morales PS4 game they're also
doing the big PS5 showcase and we're supposed
to get a Spider-Man 2 PS5 trailer tomorrow we
might get a Wolverine trailer too if we do of
course I'll do videos for that stuff but the other
literal and metaphorical big thing in the trailer
is the version of spider Rex they're actually
doing a version of spider Rex if you didn't
read the spider-verse comics spider Rex is just
a version of Spider-Man from a prehistoric Earth
in an alternate universe that got struck by a
meteorite with a bunch of alien spiders and that's
how they got their powers but it gets a little bit
weirder the origin story those characters on that
prehistoric Earth planet his original main villain
is a pterodon version of Green Goblin called
noranosaurmon which is a play on Norman Osborne
but they were both in each other's bodies the
meteor strike caused their minds to switch bodies
and gave them powers for those of you asking yes
there is a version of spectacular Spider-Man in
the background here too A lot of people wondering
about him because there's the manga verse version
of Spider-Man there's Ben Reilly Scarlet Spider
there's a bunch of other versions like Spider-Man
Unlimited from that TV show there's so many little
Easter eggs and details that they pack into
all the different frames just pause on this
one particular frame when he's fighting the
spot with all these different portals around
him flying through this version of Times Square
if you zoom in enhance around the frame there's
an ad for never 21 which is a play on Forever 21
for 2G super slow phone speeds like we're at 5G
in real life right now 2G would be really really
slow it's underneath the Sony advertisement like
we're talking about product placement brand
placement because this is a Sony Marvel movie
of course they'd want the Sony logo all over the
place in there there's an ad for Phantom of the
Opera but they're calling it Sandman which is a DC
character there's an ad for w and W's which is a
parody of M M's there's also an ad for Craven
the hunter you can see he's wearing a leopard
print jacket his trademark facial hair he looks
like a more modern businessman version of Craven
major coincidence also later this year Sony is
releasing a new Marvel Craven the hunter movie
as part of their big Sinister Six spin-offs
it's supposed to be rated R way more hardcore
than Sony's other Marvel movies they've been
doing recently really wish the Venom movies
would be rated are they released a craven trailer
at Cinema con a while ago I did a video for it so
I'll link it at the end of this but it actually
looks like it has a chance at being pretty solid
either way the movie is supposed to have an
Empire Strikes Back kind of cliffhanger type of
ending because it'll push into Spider-Man beyond
the spider-verse which will release next year
originally they said the movie just got so big
that they had to split it into two parts and
part two became beyond the spider verse and that's
why they're releasing it one year later instead of
another two or three years later so it's sort of
like their animated version of Avengers Infinity
war and Avengers end game type of spider-verse
scenario that's why I think they're building these
characters up to cross them into live action
for like a real big MCU Secret Wars crossover
eventually like how do you go bigger than some
of the stuff they're doing in this movie will you
bring the characters into live action everyone
posts all your theories about Venom crossover
all the live-action crossovers happening in the
movie of course I'll do more videos as we get
more footage too everyone click here for my Marvel
Craven the hunter trailer video in Easter eggs and
click here for my brand new secret Invasion
trailer new episodes for that coming really
soon too thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!